global migration is a pervasive reality
we have more migrants than ever in
history we even have more migrants as a
percentage of the world population just
creeping up to about three plus percent
of the world population are people who
live outside of their country of origin
they're expats economic migrants
whatever you want to call them and
that's three percent of a much larger
world population than was the case in
1950 right we're approaching a world of
seven and a half eight billion people
more than three percent of whom are now
migrants so that's nearly 300 million
people who are living outside their
country of origin who may be temporary
they may be permanent I believe that
this global migrant horde if you will is
always chasing the supply chain always
chasing jobs always chasing a better
life always chasing good cities to live
in and in fact most places in the world
are reducing the barriers to entry for
migrants in 2015 Europe led in 1 million
migrants particularly political refugees
from the Middle East now they're talking
about some limited migration controls
from the Middle East and within their
own territories across European borders
this is a very limited process because
European countries are of course largely
open to each other and generally very
integrated their supply chains their
economies are very very interdependent
but even if Europe were to impose very
strict migration restrictions that does
not tell us about the global picture the
same year 2015 ASEAN the Association of
Southeast Asian Nations which is ten
countries and 700 million people which
is greater than the population of Europe
passed an ASEAN Economic Community and
ratified a treaty to allow the free
mobility of labor across its countries
so even if in one year 600 million
people in Europe decide that they want
to limit mobility the same year 700
million people in Asia decided they want
to increase mobility so only from a
Eurocentric standpoint our walls going
up and migration becomes more difficult
that's not actually what is happening on
a worldwide basis in fact we're going
into a period that I described as a
great demographic dilution even a
genetic dilution there is so much more
intermingling of different ethnic
populations happening around the world
that there are very few countries left
that you could even dis define as
nation-states traditionally we think of
a nation-state as a country where 85 or
90 percent of the population belongs to
the same ethnic group the number of
nation-states is declining because more
and more countries are becoming more
ethnically diverse even in Europe where
the idea of the nation-state really
began in the Middle Ages and into the
modern nation-states of Western Europe
today there you see a growing percentage
of migrants and therefore those
countries are no longer even
nation-states so in fact we have this
genetic intermingling and we see this
particularly in global cities that are
melting pots places like Singapore or
Hong Kong or Dubai or Toronto or London
places where the foreign-born percentage
of the population may be 40 percent 50
percent in the case of Dubai even 85 or
90 percent of the residents actually
don't come from that place and so we see
literally mingling of ethnicities mixed
birth children and this mingling of
populations that has never taken place
before at this rapid rate so yes
populism is a feature of our politics
there is a backlash against immigration
to some degree in quite a few places but
the global picture is one of more mass
migration and integration across
societies it is very important for us to
not be deterministic about geography and
instead to always take into account the
layer of connectivity on top of
geography and the impact that has in
other words the relationship between
political geography which is our
nation's and boundaries and political
barriers
and functional geography which are the
connections that we build across those
boundaries to understand the
relationship between any two countries
you have to take into account not just
the political boundary but the
infrastructural connectivity an obvious
example is the United States and Mexico
it may be the case hypothetically that
one day if some particular person were
to become president United States he may
wish to erect some kind of a wall on the
border between the two countries which
might have the impact of reducing the
inflow into America of a very small
number of illegal migrants into the
country does that tell you everything
you need to know about us-mexico
relations not by a long shot
in fact us-mexico relations consist of
the following it is one of the world's
two or three most heavily legally
transited borders with hundreds of
thousands of people moving across every
single day it is one of the largest
trade relationships in the world with
more than a half a bit more than several
hundred billion dollars of annual trade
every single year it is two countries
that are massively investing in each
other's economies particularly the
United States now investing more and
more in the Mexican energy supply and
the Mexican energy sector in the Mexican
automotive sector and of course there's
still very large amounts of demographic
and ideational and communications and
electronics flows that are happening
between the two countries all the time
that is us-mexico relations not whether
or not there is a wall or not a wall on
the border so if you multiply that by
every single border in the world you
start to understand that there is so
much more connectivity between countries
then there is division and that's just
if we're talking about countries that
border each other but only 25% of world
trade is between countries that share a
border seventy-five percent of world
trade is between countries that are not
physically connected to each other at
all there's obviously lots of
connectivity between all of our
societies otherwise how would 75% of our
world trade be taking place at all and
in fact the value of world trade in
services
things that we zap rather than ship is
now more valuable than the trade in
goods things that we physically put in
containers and ship and so if you think
about the full almost total digital
connectivity that is encompassing the
world with the rapid spread of mobile
communications in the internet the more
you realize that even if you can't
physically see the connectivity it is
such an intimal intimate part of our
lives in our economy we know that
throughout history the great thriving
commercial and even political centers of
the world have been open diverse
tolerant melting pots ancient Greece was
like this the Roman Empire was like this
the Ottoman Empire was a very diverse
Empire the great trading centers of
European history particularly Amsterdam
were very diverse and inclusive London
during the British Empire welcomed in
people from all across the Commonwealth
and today the great global cities of the
world such as New York or Los Angeles or
London or Dubai or Singapore are all
very diverse cities in an age where we
pride cities on being thriving and
creative and innovative having services
as a dominant part of their economy
those sources of dynamism come from me
open to tall and being tolerant and open
to immigration so we find a real
correlation between the great cities in
the world the desirable places to live
and their openness to immigration and
talent and diversity and I think that's
something to celebrate